have you ever wondered what those giant
numbers the end of runways are
everything decoded runway numbers all
runways have a number between 1 and 36
this is the runways name but these are
more than just random numbers they tell
you something about your relationship
with the planet each runway number
represents its degree from magnetic
north rounded down to the nearest
two-digit number runway 12 that's
roughly a hundred and twenty degrees
from magnetic north 36 that's 360
degrees and it means you're pointed
perfectly north the numbers on the other
side of the runway are just a full 180
degrees or 18 numbers off unfortunately
magnetic north shifts over time it moves
in loops of up to 50 miles per day in
the last 150 years the pole has wandered
over 685 miles a big enough shift in
magnetic north means the runway number
has to change which means someone has to
go out at night and repaint those huge
numbers airports really hate it when
that happens